Vu qu'on a clairement des difficultés à devenir les maîtres du monde.
J'ai fait appel à un consultant pour voir où ça cafouille.
Alors...
Un petit peu cher mais il paraît que ça vaut le coup.
Alors, mon travail ici c'est de faire un bilan de compétence de groupe.
Mais ça c'est alimentaire, parce qu'en vrai mes passions...
C'est la botanique, les courses de chariots...
Et la natation synchronisée.
Pour évaluer le potentiel d'un groupe, en général...
Je prends le premier jour pour les points faibles.
Le deuxième jour, les points forts.
Et le troisième jour, on fait une synthèse.
Avec eux, j'en suis à 4 jours de points faibles.
J'ai dû annuler des trucs perso et tout...
Quelles sont vos principales qualités ?
Les épées !
C'est pas une qualité.
Si !
Avec la vitesse.
Quels sont vos principaux défauts ?
Quand je cours, on dirait que je nage.
Effectivement.
Comment rendre hommage à un noble ?
Non.
Y a rien de sexuel dans la question, hein.
C'est... Comment saluer un noble ?
Salutation.
Pourquoi l'accent ?
Combien de langues parlez vous ?
Je comprends pas la question.
Ok.
Voilà.
Quelle serait votre première décision si vous étiez roi ?
Le droit d'avoir 1000 voeux !
Je parle de décision, y a pas de génie dans l'histoire.
Ah oui... J'abolirai le royalisme !
Donc vous vous annulez quoi ?
Exact !
Je suis bon en énigme.
Alors, j'ai étudié vos faiblesses.
Que j'ai ajouté dans ce tableau.
J'ai aussi, bien sûr, étudié vos forces.
Mais il semblerait que vous n'en ayez pas.
Est-ce qu'on peut apprendre quelque chose qu'on ne sait pas déjà ?
Lâcheté, incompétences sociales, problèmes de lecture...
C'était écrit petit...
Il faut savoir qu'une armée a entre 7000 et 10,000 soldats.
Vous, 183 villageois.
C'est des fermiers-soldats.
Ouais bah en attendant y en a 2 qui m'ont rendu leur armure en pensant qu'ils étaient pompiers.
La seule dame du palais est pas instruite pour la cour.
Et votre chef...
Il a pas vraiment l'autorité.
Alors ça, si...
J'ai pas fini !
Exact !
Donc, pour conquérir le trône de fer...
J'ai 3 solutions en tête.
Soit, vous pouvez prouver que vous avez un vrai fils de dragon, descendant de l'ancien roi.
Soit, vous trouvez une stratégie dans laquelle...
Les points forts seraient d'avoir énormément de points faibles.
Soit vous avez une sorcière qui créer un univers parallèle...
Dans lequel vous seriez l'exact opposé des gros ringards que vous êtes, à l'heure actuelle.
Je me casse.
Les remises en question c'est toujours positif.
Sauf celle-là.
Celle-là je la trouve déprimante.
Ok, on est peut-être pas près tout de suite, tout de suite...
Mais... on a quelques pistes hein !
On va réfléchir à des stratégies...
Prendre une sorcière aussi, ça serait pas mal.
Mais le mieux, ça serait eux.
Je l'ai dit mais c'est pas possible.